et nous ouvrons à cette édition avec les
hommages rendus à michel rocard l'ancien
premier ministre maire emblématique de
confiance en taurine de 1977 à 1994 est
mort samedi 2 juillet à l'âge de 85 ans
des suites d'une maladie
député des yvelines dès 1969 sénateurs
de 1995 à 1997 il incarner cette
deuxième gauche sociale-démocrate
ministre d'état dans les gouvernements
mauroy et fabius michel rocard en train
matignon le 10 mai 1988 au début du
second septennat de françois mitterrand
il y restera trois ans à conflans sainte
honorine à ville où il a exercé les
fonctions de maire pendant 17 ans un
grand nombre d'hommages lutte ont été
rendus devant la section à socialistes
ils sont nombreux à avoir déposé des
roses comme vous le voyez des habitants
aussi ont été très touché et ému par
cette disparition je vous propose de les
écouter quelqu'un de simple et de de
direct voilà un qui en on a confiance
j'aimerais bien que le monde politique
lui ressemble un peu plus en ce moment
et pour large aux ça m'attriste mais
c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup à
cette année mais très bien c'était bien
bien géré la ville de conflans c'est
naturel je ne suis pas socialiste mais
je trouve pour c'était quelqu'un de très
bien franchement vraiment il il a fait
beaucoup de choses et notamment le rmi
tettey qui a aidé beaucoup de gens et en
même temps pour les peaux les
fonctionnaires il a été aussi très très
très bien je crois qu'ils étaient au
dessus de la politique qui vraiment je
crois que c'est vraiment ce qu'on
retiendra de lui principalement faute et
l'actuel maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine l'auront
bruxelles les républicains s'est
également exprimée suite à cette
disparition il était ce matin au micro
de patrick chef de dixmude elle et c'est
une grâce particulière en matière de
culture
il a créé la médiathèque
il a créé également le théâtre simone
signoret il a modernisé le conservatoire
de musique
on se rencontre sera travers les
hommages qui sont rendus ces derniers
jours et ces dernières heures encore que
finalement ces hommages sont issus de
toutes les sensibilités politiques
alors il a d'une certaine façon dépasser
les clivages
ces dernières années mais il faut quand
même se rappeler que dans les années 80
sans donner le meilleur et pas moins un
socialiste bien assumé et enfin la
municipalité de conflans sainte honorine
organise un rassemblement en hommage à
son ancien premier magistrat ce sera ce
soir lundi 4 juillet à 20 heures devant
l'hôtel de ville
la classe politique français s'était
également très largement exprimée suite
à cette disparition et à s'élever
l'homme politique son engagement mais
aussi sa carrière pierre et bédié
président du conseil départemental a
salué la mémoire d'un grand serviteur de
la france mais aussi l'un des français
les plus humbles dans un communiqué de
presse à saint quentin en yvelines les
élus ont également réagi et se sont
souvenus de lui je vous propose
d'écouter quelques réactions il avait un
parler franc parler vrai moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours plu et
qui me manque aujourd'hui c'est
important de savoir dire les choses et
de prendre des décisions et surtout de
savoir s'engager malgré ce que l'on peut
attendre en retour il avait été maire et
ensuite il a été député premier mini
sénateurs je veux dire c'est quelqu'un
qui a eu un parcours politique d'une
expérience incroyable et qui
véritablement je crois travailler pour
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'intérêt
général dans les yvelines de plus grande
partie des militants ont été re car bien
de soit de manière directe ou indirecte
c'est une situation qui était évidemment
rocardienne qui s'est construit autour
aussi ce personnage tout à fait
particulier politiquement quitté michel
rocard et donc oui vous interrogez
n'importe quel militant il aura toujours
des anecdotes vous raconter sur les
campagnes qu'il a mené avec michel ou
sur des parcours qu'ils ont eu en commun
donc c'est une personnalité actuellement
marquante pour nous c'est une grande
tristesse parce que
pour moi c'était un ami et un patron
j'ai commencé mon apprentissage
politique avec lui au psu c'est un homme
d'une telle intelligence d'une telle
réflexion
j'aimais beaucoup son esprit son esprit
créatif et enthousiaste en même temps ce
qui manque beaucoup
il me semble aux nouvelles générations
en politique c'est plutôt un homme
simple sincère constructif constructif
c'était pas du tout un démolisseur comme
on l marxiste qui veut faut détruire
l'entreprise le chef d'entreprise le
droit du travail ça nous étouffer
l'entreprise ça doit le mettre en danger
un gamin soit michel aulas est le
premier homme d'état socialiste qui a
osé poser cette question il s'est même
fâché avec françois mitterrand
souvenez-vous parce qu'il ne voulait pas
il voulait justement que le parti
socialiste ne gardent cet axe comme tous
les partis socialistes bien sûr européen
de couper avec cette vision très
archaïque de l'économie autre réaction
écoutons à présent benoît hamon il y
parlait de michel rocard sur notre
antenne c'était l'an dernier lors de
l'émission à café politique michel
rocard influent lors des premières
années en politique de l'ancien ministre
michel rocard un homme qui a été
influent pour vous vous avez été le
président fondateur du mouvement des
jeunes socialistes
et c'est michel rocard qui a donné un
petit peu débordante l'autonomie aa77
formation c'est surprenant michel rocard
c'est plutôt le libéral c'est pas la
veuve de la gauche non mais ça c'est
vraiment classe non mais c'est pas ça
c'est qu'aucun s'est montré à son père
grossièrement coteaux du ps et lui
mitterrand la gauche n'osera dire car la
droite
la réalité c'est que quand vous regardez
quand on lit quand on prend le temps de
lire michel rocard on voit par exemple
dans la critique qu'il a de la
financiarisation de l'économie d'un
développement d'une forme de capitalisme
dévoyé et c'est qu'ils se désintéressent
finalement de l'outil industriel pause
se préoccuper que de la rentabilité
nature et du capital
il a eu un discours très fort et des
propositions qui ont été très
importantes et quand on voit la place
qu'il a accordé lui à la question par
exemple climatique il ya un des premiers
socialistes à cette emparé de cette
question là où qu'honnêtement on a été
nous la gauche très en retard des skis
étaient les prises de conscience dans la
société civile ou du côté d'europe
écologie les verts par exemple de
l'importance aujourd'hui du climat et de
l'environnement et pourquoi est ce que
c'est important déjà parce que quand
l'environnement se dégrade sa touche au
qui en premier les catégories les plus
vulnérables les plus modestes
c'est pour ça que l'enjeu
environnemental c'est aussi un enjeu
social des associations là haut car oui
ça a été une
ça reste une référence mais pour la
gauche même pour ceux qui ont commencé
politique n'est pas revue depuis
longtemps vont être très honnête de
recroiser l'année dernière ça reste une
référence
intellectuel que je respecte le traité
de conserve des points d'accord
évidemment et refermant à cette page
hommage avec un dernier extrait en
février 2011 michel rocard était
l'invité de patrice carmouze un échange
dans le cadre de la sortie notamment de
son ouvrage est si ça vous amuse
l'histoire de son parcours de ses
combats et de ses engagements écouter
l'ancien premier ministre parlait de la
social démocratie le courant qui
l'internet la france n'a jamais connu la
social démocratie et du coup elle ne
connaît pas le dialogue social
elle ne connaît pas l'équilibré
la france vit avec des pulsions brutale
le front populaire la libération mais 58
on change à propos de l'algérie de
constitution mai 68 la france entière en
grève générale pour demander une autre
infection du pouvoir qui n'entend rien
politiquement mais qui entend beaucoup
culturellement et sociologiquement nous
ne sommes pas en social démocratie et
c'est dommage parce que c'est une
manière de s'adapter les uns au zoo de
s'écouter mieux sans brutalité
avec plus de progressivité